you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
george lopez
george lopez oh my god omg omg
hi oh my god
you think if they made a flute out of
skin that they would play
a real flute i think not the one from
puff and stuff
not the one who talks another one i
think they can make that work do you
know that every time i listen to the
puffin stuff song
did i play it oh it made me start crying
uh well throws you back there that and
brian's song i think me and you the
poster for this show should be brian's
song like
i'll be gayle sayers and you'll be uh
james connie right and then the song
plays
and we start crying oh just like
just like in the hawk when he left town
and they used to play that sad song
every time he went to a town like my
uncle he he'd get [ __ ] up
like mom would go to sumar with a
[ __ ] bleeding eye and i'd say where
were you and he would say [ __ ] so mark
as if the whole town had kicked his ass
only my uncle could come back with a
[ __ ] torn mouth there and he'd be
like
[ __ ] fedco you know like if if the owner
of feckle kicked him in his face
his clothes were all torn or even at
gemco which everybody had a beautiful
experience
he did it who didn't have a beautiful
experience at gemco
that was one of my favorite places in
the world i used to work at fedco
and uh you know i'm a little bit removed
and there was this girl that was a
[ __ ] hot man
at fed killed working on
you know pocket out there beautiful
[ __ ] knobs like trying to think ksj
[ __ ] radio knobs yeah i think even
it even had numbers on her nipples and
what happened
mhs megahertz and i was saying kg
kilograms
did you make a move you ever seen a
nipple that had hairs around it
uh yeah those are under the
electrical problem here
if you touch them both or you get a
spark merrier
it'll start your engine i never thought
i would get remarried and then some girl
told me one time i don't have a gag
reflex and i got on one knee and i said
with this ring ivy wed
all right what's this show going to be
about it's going to be a faith-based
show
good because i have faith that by the
time i finish this i'm about to be all
by myself
okay come on hey look at that a girl
that was keep
calling her face down her face still
[ __ ] something
horvath jeremy
we are yeah today is going to be a
family in the park
a month after i would say what are you
doing because i'm doing practicing that
name
horror back all on this part what's
today
today is uh we are with edward are you a
religious individual or are you not
would you grow up catholic i did grow
catholic my mother was a very strict
catholic my father switched from
methodist to catholic to marry my mother
he was great at the reception
yeah unfortunately he didn't what's your
dad's ways 24
nobody my dad is a very thin waist yeah
i am
i'm on about it from wild wild west
the little james conrad yeah james cowan
with a little magic the little [ __ ]
yeah he was a little kid yeah man
what was uh his character ananito was
conrad's character name
you know was it mr jones james west
james west and he said mr
west the little guy i like my character
uh
captain james t good ass to be my
so we'll be on a golf course and
there'll be a guy with really tight
pants on he's showing us crack through
there he's all late gentlemen
captain james t good ass
check out all the captains james good
ass
yeah i can't i never escape but anyways
uh edward james almost
almost excuse me and kathleen quinlan on
the show today
amazing actors and you actually walking
with her walking with her
co-starring george lopez in this movie
so it's going to be
quite a show to actually be able to talk
to them about working with you
you know um if you think about faith and
you think about
you know even just mentioning that like
right now when i think about faith
in san fernando when i was growing up in
seminole california and i would go to
the comedy store in westwood this is
called this is like
june of 1979. and i wasn't very
religious my grandmother
was or my grandfather was not biological
i keep saying
and he would pray in the room
like i would walk by he'd be praying by
the side of the bed
and he wouldn't go to church and he
would make me and my grandmother go
and i would say how come you're not
going he goes because i [ __ ] pray
here
and they go straight up you i don't know
what the [ __ ] you're doing you need to
go to the main office
mine i could do them here yeah but you
need to go talk to
so i don't think i ever told this story
so
as an 18 year old young man just out of
high school
on monday on monday around two or three
in the afternoon
i would go to saint ferdinand's church
in san fernando
and i would sit toward the back of the
church there was nobody there maybe one
lady or two and i would get on my knees
and i would i would pray
that i would do well that night and that
i would
not be afraid to go up because you
didn't know when you signed up
and that somehow god would bless me
wow and i did it every time so once i do
something once
like i have to do it and keep doing it
and in the middle of that summer
i go there and
i'm on my knees and i'm praying and i
look down at the book
and there's a paper sticking out of the
book
and the paper pretty much says if you
believe
in what you believe that everything that
you imagine can be accomplished
wow a written paper
not part of the books it was sticking
out of the book
and i don't know where it came from i
don't know who wrote it
or i don't know how it got there but
when i sat in that pew and i looked down
that paper was there that is crazy
by my throat you know who wrote i wrote
it i thought you didn't read the back
i said [ __ ] the point of your your p-hoy
god said that so but but but
unbelievably to me like i
i looked at it as an endorsement
because i would have never met you know
going there i went from
it didn't make me better or didn't make
me worse but somehow it just gave me
um i'm not sure what it gave me it gave
me the the strength and confidence to
get up there that's hard man
i was you know i grew up in san fernando
a little chicano kid like just 18.
nobody was going to the comedy store
yeah you know and to go and do that
and then to have the balls to go
up there when i was shy and couldn't
even talk to anybody yeah crazy
i was i was shy i couldn't talk about if
you leave me in the room with a with a
mega a lot of my even though a mexican
magazine a lot of my that would have all
the car accidents in mexico and in the
middle out of center ball
i would fire up things there'll be a
[ __ ] three alarm fire right there in
a hotel people jumping out of the window
and then in the middle they had a girl
with tassels right there i was like no
matter what the problem
right so did that that was that a ritual
of yours for a long long time then
obviously was it i mean you you did that
for how long okay yes and then
the day that we
the day that we went to go pitch stu
bloomberg at abc for my first show
me bruce and sandra and everybody i went
to freddie prinze's grave
at forest lawn and
the meeting was at like 2 i went there
like 10 30.
and i don't know why i went there you
know i had stolen the
headstone years before and decades ago
at least at least 24 25 years
earlier but i went
and i said that all i needed was the
opportunity like i don't know why i went
there it's like
why why you could just go to a
fire hydrant it means the same thing but
to me it meant something to go there
and me that wasn't even my church saying
for a dance i used to go to santa rosa
that's a
that's another one and then across the
street the bakery is the bakery that we
use
for ching on basically right there at
the very best across the street from san
francisco
so i go there and i say you know
i mean i'm so close but i'm not there
yet i'm going to
i'm going to abc at two o'clock i go for
a print scrape i'm like just
i just i just want a chance
we go there me bruce robert
sandra bullet comes in she's dressed
incredibly almost like
remember when she came out of the
elevator in the corner like in miss
congeniality when she comes out of the
airport you can't play hangout like that
i'm like whoa
you know like santa was all business
when we go to stu brumberg's office i'm
sitting on the couch and we're looking
across his desk
and he's sitting on the other side of
the couch so it's us here chair there
he's there
and stu bloomberg says it's kind of dark
in here isn't it let me go open the
window and he opens a window and abc is
is across the freeway the 134 freeway
from forest lawn so stupid gets up hits
a button and the curtains open
and from where i'm sitting i can see
where freddie prinze is buried
through the window at abc wow and
you know he bought the show
and we went forward but why would he
open the window right
and you recognize it right away again uh
i was sitting there and he opened the
and the and the blinds opened like this
and i could see
through there and i thought i was just
there four hours ago
literally begging for an opportunity to
who i don't know
wow and then it happens
do you still do you still then i burn
myself in a kitchen fire
[Laughter]
do you still find yourself doing that
though is that like the go-to
um the move no no
you you know i i don't you know and it's
interesting because
you know of all things that have
happened none
none you take for granted like you
always don't want to be in hbo you do
like four of those and you do everything
but um i wouldn't say that i'm
i'm more or less of a believer because
i'm
the buddhist principles but also to not
do people harm like before i would i
would always
do people at home i always think awful
things of people but i'm not that person
anymore
but i was when i was growing up
somebody would [ __ ] die but i finally
i'm the only person that [ __ ] yelled
out finally
my mom died finally because my
grandmother would yell that i better
want to see my grandma one time she was
in the sierra memorial hospital right
there
in up in uh kind of lakeview terrace and
there was a lady that kept yelling god
take me my girl was like
[ __ ] lazy all night and the next day
she was gone i said what happened
thank god he took her she died overnight
oh my god but that was that was i became
a
a younger version of my grandmother man
how about that well today can we stop
all this [ __ ]
by the way your alcohol counsel has not
oh man
giving me that you know that i need to
stamp these cans
i meant lethal they're uh they're
serious you know how [ __ ] bad this
beer is this bottle is upside down
on the thing i'm gonna get that tattoo
so when you when you
did this would you oh my gosh let me
start over
when you film no i understand with
edward james almost
the biggest it was the biggest part um
that i had ever um
that i had ever done but it but in
knowing it was a faith-based
movie did that did that make you feel
like you uh
more comfortable less comfortable uh
same amount of comfortableness on set
did you think i'm gonna say that um
well i'm not i'm not a trained actor per
se
but i look at your life as experiences
you know
part of that movie was very emotional
where you you can cry on camera there's
a couple movies that i've done
where you had to cry on cue not a lot of
i worked with an actress one time and
she went into
the closet and they put some like onion
water drops in her eyes he starts crying
faked it i was able to
cry without the use of that
a lot of times in movies because of my
background i would just think of
something
that happened to me and it would make me
start crying
like the day i got married
that's the joke that's a joke uh
sequence that goes on
well share with everybody what it was
when you when you were crying at
when you cried in this movie
[ __ ]
listen what you're thinking just because
everything that goes through you tell
everybody can we just keep some secrets
about this movie
then why see a movie if i'm not telling
the whole plot i'm just thinking there's
there is a scene you just
shared with everybody that you cried
what about if somebody saw deep throat
already tells you that that lady's gonna
probably take it all the way down to the
pedals eh
but are you gonna be the one that's
gonna break our hearts and tell us that
that her clitoris is in her throat
i hope not man that'd be cool let's let
john leslie be the judge of that
god rest his soul a lot of pornos have
died eh yeah
there's a there's a there's a horror
movie right there
was like what's up i'm just thinking
about all the pornos
[Music]
1776. oh my god uh and who else
um annette jurgensen that's not a name
jurgensen jurgensen
oh that's good okay outstanding
um yeah well my thing was was there
something
not to not to give away the movie was
something you thought of that made you
you know this time this time no this
time it was uh the time that was very
emotional it was
just out of the interaction with uh mr
olmos
how about that that's impressive i
didn't i didn't need to remember
something bad
to do it was just because of
and really maybe for the first time when
you're so engulfed in a character
that that i didn't expect that to happen
it wasn't written
for it to happen wow um but i think just
out of my respect
and my admiration for him right and he
didn't expect it either though he was
throwing a little bit not thrown but he
was somewhat surprised by it yeah
impressive he told me if there's another
riot can we go out there and sweep the
streets i said [ __ ] you
and there you go remember on the riots
and ellie who's out there sweeping the
streets
yeah i do that was that was that was
that's an iconic moment
him doing that
i don't mean to be laughing all right uh
enough of us to let's get down with
kevin
quinlan and edward james okay let me try
it again take two
fantastic george let's get out of there
jade's over the [ __ ] world
okay kathleen quinlan and james thomas
are waiting in the wings
okay all right we shouldn't drink before
i'll tell you about it
before we get they're not wasting the
wings [ __ ] at their house
not the wings
brought to you by zoom today is captured
remember this show is brought to you by
the horvath university horvath
how's your uncle called nature's ken as
theo says
horror [ __ ] remember theo nature's candy
that's my field told me
i should make what was mitch's candy all
right and i'm with the interview
[Music]
who's doing the interest right brian
you're prepared i am prepared i believe
so
i think so oh [ __ ] hi i'm i'm ready to
go
i can't see your face brian you're not
lit really
oh man sorry that's okay you know what
you might be all right
it'd be better that i'm shaded
you know i'm not i never consider myself
truly attractive but brian
wait can you tell who it is now that no
yeah
is simply decorations you can't breathe
out of it it doesn't work
it doesn't work it's really just
decorative this is why i cannot
ever enter the witness protection
program anywhere because i'll be found
out
in a second hey tell him tell him that
time you were at disneyland now with
that girl
check this out i went to disneyland and
i'm with a girl and she's my dream girl
she went out with me i could not believe
that she was
with me and and we're standing in one of
those super three hour long lines in
disneyland
that snakes around and there's a uh
probably a three-year-old
in front of me in the arms of his father
and he looks at me and he goes
wow you got a nose like a witch and
everybody heard it
and they started laughing so i still had
three more hours to wait in line so
every time they passed me
they they laughed at me for three hours
straight because i had a nose
exactly like a witch and my girl my
little girl you know my friend my
girlfriend was just she
she couldn't she was like she joined in
with them and started laughing with them
so it made things even better the
greatest night of my life
that guy's gotta know like a witch and
the whole place blew up they all started
laughing
ah okay that's all right
character built a lot of character that
night right
that's right but thank you for being
here my gosh what
what an honor to have you on the podcast
and um george i don't know if you want
to introduce your friends or would you
like me to throw uh
my homage to them i want you to do it
okay well we have uh
two academy award nominated actors in
the house today
uh we'll start with uh miss quinlan uh
she's in some of my favorite movies and
i don't know if you guys even uh
american graffiti lifeguard apollo 13
uh unbelievable economy academy
nominated actress
kathleen quinlan thank you so much for
being here and we have
also that's all she's done is five
movies and all this stuff
she's done a gajillion movies but those
are those are my my personal favorites
lifeguard being my favorite favorite but
but she has been nominated for an
academy award
and uh she is an amazing actress over uh
i don't want to say how many decades
maybe four decades five decades of work
amazing actress and we also have mr
olmos
uh uh golden globe winner academy award
nominee
and been in uh started miami vice
american
only brian could make you feel inferior
when he's reading off your
accomplishments i don't know how the
[ __ ] i don't know how somebody has
the gift
of reading somebody's accomplishments
and when he's done you feel like
i'm a failure right when that's why
people meet at the eagles club we all
talk about this and this is what we
learned
but uh miami vice american me stand and
deliver blade runner
mayans as well as the upcoming walking
with her of course mr edward james
almost thank you so much
thank you very much thank you very much
to have you here and mr jordan i i kind
of i know what eddie
was doing when he was young and i think
he aspired to be an actor
i don't think that you aspire to be
an actress you have i think when we talk
one of those stories that
you think you know somebody's at schwabs
or somebody somewhere and they say
you know have you ever considered doing
this and you were doing something
completely different would you want to
share that with us
if i can remember yes
i was poking around do all sorts of
things i
i thought i was i was studying to be a
marine biologist
and oh wow um
but then i found out that i couldn't
finish the courses at the college i was
at and they said oh go to san francisco
state i said i can't afford to
go to san francisco state how am i going
to do that
and i didn't know there was such a thing
as the scholarship so
i was doing a lot of sports gymnastics
and
five meter diving and somebody said
there was
an audition for american graffiti and i
i took drama classes but i didn't think
you could make a living at it i was
really looking to make a living
and so somebody picked me out of all the
people
studying for my scuba diving license
and somebody picked me out in the
hallway and asked me to come in this
room with these guys
you know george lucas and gino havens
and steven spielberg
and and i read a little thing and they
said well
come and come and do this part they said
okay well i'm
i'm a living babysitter all summer on
catalina island but i'll come back
and you're ready
wow wow
i thought well maybe i can get paid to
do this you never know
but you know american graffiti became
kind of like
the definitive movie of a person's youth
did it feel like that when they were
doing it no
no it felt like the circus came to town
you know i was living up in mill valley
next to sausalito there wasn't fancy
then
and so all these movie stars came and
they had trailers all over our high
school
and and i didn't recognize that era
at all that wasn't my era my hair was
the
young hippies smoking pot and you know
hanging out so
and then after when did you come to
hollywood whether you said somebody
what's up hollywood uh
with a friend by yourself i came by
myself
i i the night before
um i had some friends in la
and so the night before
my mom was she could have kept me till i
was 19 i was 18.
we drank a bunch of tequila i took 50
of my clothes and i moved down to l.a
and i paid
room and board at the ortez's
the ortez's all the latino people took
care of me
not the white people oh your judges took
care of me the orbeez
took care of me uh you know
so i was lucky
you know i had a job i was a waitress
took about three months and i said well
that's
that was fun but i'm not doing that
anymore
i got a job so
go ahead how long was it after you moved
to los angeles that you started
working actually after moving to los
angeles
well you have to be really naive so
i i made you know my goal you know in
three months i wanted to work and
in one year i wanted to do a major
part in a film and in
those days that was oh that was a little
possible and so i did a part in
emergency
of course of course johnny gage yeah
and i walked over barefoot for the
meeting
at universal wow it was a hot day
and when i did the
lifeguard you know with um
dan petrie and sam elliott ann archer
one of my favorite movies within a year
yeah
i had a great time i swam in the ocean
all day so
yeah that's a great perfect job
well done that's pretty amazing isn't it
i mean
you come down with 50 bucks you're
hungover from hanging out with your mom
drinking tequila and then the mexicans
take care of you and then
you meet sam elliott and ann archer and
you you're in lifeguards swimming in the
ocean doing a movie
okay so how'd this happen how did this
happen
oh that's great that is fantastic
um did you ever by chance ever go to
the whiskey or the roxy and see edward
james almost
as the house band at the place where
when you were the house band you were
destined for stardom
eddie tell tell everybody who were the
house bands
and when you became the house band at
khazari's
or the whiskey you were destined for
stardom
you know that was an era that i'm so
grateful that i had a chance to exist
and understand
i started playing rock and roll in the
garage you know like most rock and
rollers do garage bands
and i was 14 years old and we got our
first break
by playing for like 15 minutes
on a weekend at the uh uh
uh with the prestonps at uh
pandora's box that pandora's box was
right
in the little kind of island
no no no no it's the it's the on sunset
boulevard
right okay as you're coming over laurel
canyon becomes crescent heights
it's like that little island that's
where there's a little house
and we started playing there and and
that was a lot of fun with the preston
amps they would play and then we'd play
for like 10-15 minutes we were terrible
but uh you know rock and roll in those
days was a little bit different it was a
little more
innocent and you know as long as you
could play three chords you could get
through it
and i screamed that's all i ever did
it was good and it was fun and then i
went over and started playing it
uh at gazari's on the sunset strip and
uh we started playing there for free
and we followed in um red bone
oh wow okay red bone was playing wow man
that played there for nine straight
months
and before them it was uh jim morrison
and the doors
that had been on that stage playing
there for months and months and months
that's where they got their start
and then they moved over to the whiskey
and then they went on to
pacific ocean park pop and then became
the doors and
they they went screaming out and uh same
with red
bull and red bone at that time was pat
and lolly vegas they weren't known as
redbone
and but then they went off and then we
took over the stage
and uh pat when he left he says you've
got to keep the stage for at least nine
months to beat our record dude
i said okay i would love to be able to
do that man if they'll give me a job
here for nine months
i'd be so happy i spent four years seven
nights a week
oh my gosh wow held the record
until we handed it over to van halen
oh man halen took it for four years in
one week
wow oh no kidding yeah
they get they they broke everybody's
record and uh it was wonderful
but that's uh you know i i got started
in rock and roll
and i was a terrible rock and roll
singer um i sing flat but
when you're singing rock and roll like i
said before you're singing in a pa
system they usually weren't really great
so you kind of like could hear the voice
but you really couldn't tone it down as
to being a you know it wasn't a
studio recording in the studio so and i
screamed
and i danced that was an entertainer
that's what i was i was an entertainer
period
and so my uh entertainment got me into
when i went to college
when i was 17 years old i took an acting
class
i'm the only i think the only actor so
far that's come out of east los angeles
community college
and it's been successful wow
congratulations yeah it's really a
tremendous understanding
but i went there and i started working
as an actor and
along with my music because i was doing
going to school during the day
doing that stuff that night i'd be
playing at the
desires on this trip so from 64 to 68
that's what i did
and then on 68 i moved to the factory
which i don't know did you ever kathleen
did you ever get a chance to see that
place
no but you were too young you you
wouldn't have seen that it was 1968 it
was owned by uh
paul newman uh wow um
you know where was it on um it was
sunset as well
no no no it was on lapeer between santa
monica and melrose there's a little
street called
pier and it was an old factory building
and they they'd never touch the outside
and they would drive a car up you know
the the lamborghinis and all these
expensive cars would drive up and a guy
would run out of a little door
what didn't we have a big door or
anything he had a little door with a
light bulb that was hanging by the court
you know just hanging there like that
he'd run out jump in the car
the people would rush into the car into
the place
and the car would take off and he
wouldn't see it there was no
there was a huge parking lot that was
full of dirt but they never used it
and so no one knew that this place was
happening they had tinted the windows
black
so you couldn't see inside and you
couldn't see light coming out
and you'd ride up an old storage
elevator you'd go up at an old storage
elevator you know really
creepy and ugly and dirty felt dirty
just getting into it
and you go up and as you're going up to
the next floor
you'd start to see that the unbelievable
crystal chandeliers
and the unbelievable wealth
this was one of the most exclusive
nightclubs in the world at that time
and i performed there for two years
straight and i performed for
wow i performed for judy garland for
this door
i mean for the stones the beatles you
know all of these
great great performers would come there
because it cost you a lot of money to be
up
to be able to get in you had to really
pay a lot of money to be a member
i mean a lot of money so people who were
there were very very wealthy and we
played there for
a few years and uh and i was
honestly by using music
and movement and theater
when i got zoot suit the play
which was all of those things it was
music it was theater it was
you know dancing and singing
and it was all of those things put
together like they say i was lucky
and lucky to me is when you're prepared
for the opportunity
that's the line okay so you have a
musical background
you're also very athletic you're quite a
baseball player yeah i was
and then you were an actor yeah now you
could
you know we could be honest or we could
you could tell me what
i think you you want me to tell but if
of those three
which would you have done
at that particular time because i know
you love music and i know you love
baseball and acting but
what would i mean it's all giving you
yeah joy you're very good at what you
what you've done i mean you know you get
to the point where you just
are fortunate that you were given the
opportunity to understand it
and i understood it i really did i
helped produce
uh my music my my records i helped write
my music
then i went on to produce theater
and and and write plays and
working off off off valet theater which
is really far off of broadway
right and and and then went on to to
excel to the point of where i went on
broadway i got into broad 1978
the very first major piece of work that
has ever been
on the latino culture in the history of
theater
and it was on broadway and i won the
tony nomination and
it was an amazing experience doing el
pachuco but of all of those i mean
i was playing baseball at the age of 13
and 14 i was catching like eddie roebuck
and i was playing
in in the single a ball and it was
the winner league for pros that's what i
was playing already
and i was a little kid i wasn't really
built at all i wasn't
but the thing was that they were
grooming me
and they saw that i was there and i knew
how to play the game and i played it
very very well and i was a very good
hitter in my league the golden
i won the gold california golden state
champ battling championship for two
years in a row
i was batting over 400 you know it was
like amazing
i mean like considering low so everybody
thought i was gonna be a ballplayer and
sort of my dad and
and then i got i heard rock and roll
1956 57 man rock and roll started coming
in by
1960 i was whoa man i started singing
with my next-door neighbor who played
guitar
he played guitar this before the stones
just before the beatles before any of
those
we're listening to you know richie
valens and buddy holly and we're
listening to
you know little richard uh all of those
players you know
and uh and and playing our little music
and stuff in the garage and that's how
music got involved
and i stopped playing baseball and
everybody freaked out and my father
freaked out everybody i mean
you know i was playing with bobby knop
and gary cannot the cannot brothers
were playing could bobby cannot went off
to become the manager of the
coach of the angels for 10 years
and and you know with george pena and
all these great great
you know rick fenton was the one who was
carrying me and teaching me how to play
him and tony parra and uh they they
brought me through and
when i stopped they really got hurt they
all got hurt
and that really was a big change
hey man i want to say you rock and roll
oh my god are you kidding
you're you're a ball player but right
wrong with you
and so i got in with the discipline
determination and perseverance and
patience that i had learned playing
baseball
because i couldn't play baseball when i
started i couldn't even catch a ball
but i disciplined myself to do the
things i loved to do when i didn't feel
like doing them
and i did it seven days a week like
musicians play music they do it seven
days a week you don't mess around
you do it every day you know people say
you can't do something every day i say
how many of you brush your teeth every
day
you brush them every day and you don't
even like it but you do it anyway
so that being said i used that which i'd
learned the discipline determination
perseverance and patience and i just
got into music and used the same thing
and i did seven days a week
and pretty soon i was really the best
that i could be not better than anybody
i wasn't better than anybody else
i was lucky that i was able to just feel
comfortable standing up on the stage
that's why i took acting classes
to learn how to be a performer up on
stage
and so and singing rock and roll and
then when zutsu came along man
it just shot right through the roof and
i'm not kidding you
from zoot suit on out i had total
creative control of my character from
that moment on
to this moment to this day right i
control the characters that i perform it
and that was the biggest change in my
life now you asked me which one of the
three
i i watch baseball every day i watch i
watch every game the dodgers play man
i watch every single i watch all i miss
one game during the pre-season
and you know tonight i'm waiting to
we're going to win tonight
the a's and uh you know so we'll see
anyway well you and i and kathleen
that's an interesting
time we had a great time watching
watching this
great you're a great athlete okay george
people don't even know it you're a great
athlete not a good one
a great one you yourself saying come on
eddie no well you know as you get older
you start to realize that you weren't as
talented
i never did well with women like i can i
can
i can understand that because if they're
not around you it's
easy to tell that you're not very good
and
look at mine they're all over me
you know and i think that's part of the
bravado of like oh yeah
uh you know she's lucky you know
yeah they are we're lucky i left them
alone but as i got older i started to
realize like every one time i made a big
deal
when i was 15 because i didn't make it
to the all-star team and i thought i
should have and then now
i realized i sucked i was like just
being this pain in the ass kid
like hey how come i didn't make it i was
awful so in hindsight you look back in
hindsight and you go okay i mean some
athletic ability but
not as not as much as i as i
as i thought i think i had enough that
god had given me enough
athletic ability to make friends that i
was going to end up keeping a long time
because of baseball a lot of those guys
i'm still friends with
40 years later um
and i think taking them to the games and
all that stuff
is a really nice thing because you grow
up you know when you're in high school
all
five guys in the car and you're going to
the games and all this stuff and then
later on
you're able to take those guys on the
field and meet some of the players is
is really nice i still was very affected
by it
by all of that like meeting your heroes
who did you meet kathleen when you came
to hollywood that you thought wow that's
so and so
anybody i mean i'm sure you're no it
wasn't uh
let me think there was it wasn't so much
uh i wasn't very celebrity
in awe of sort of um
but i i do remember i met olivia de
havilland
wow and i went now there's a real
woman a real lady and she was very
exciting i got more excited when i met
uh captain james lovell oh wow
you know headed up the actual apollo 13
mission to me that was like and then
when i met
oh my god you're gonna kill me i'll
think of them but
um so that was very exciting and i also
remember
when i was frustrated early on
uh as an actor you know because i wasn't
used to not working consistently
and i wrote a letter to jacques cousteau
and i said i'll work in the kitchen i'll
do whatever you want just
can i come work for you i never i didn't
get an
answer but wow was there ever a time
though i mean you had a great uh
acting career of course was there ever
time that you regretted
leaving marine biology behind
um no not so much yeah not really marine
biology so much because
sadly i see what we do to the ocean
and i knew it was going to be really
painful to watch
and it is but
i i i did it was hard to leave
athletics athletics is my number one
that's what i love the most
but in those days you could not
do anything like a commercial or any
kind of promotion
you would lose your amateur status and
then you couldn't compete
but i can't make any money doing this
you know
yeah so i decided i'd just keep it as my
first
love and you know well i gotta tell you
i gotta tell you kathleen you're gonna
really just like
i'll go nuts i used to we during miami
vice
in miami in 1984 when we started there
jacques cousteau would park the calypso
and maybe
get it to get it serviced to get it
serviced
and he invited he would invite me over
they would be working on their boats and
stuff you know cleaning it and
everything
right and then i would bring i brought
uh
hbo i think you know was it what was it
some kind of
of uh of a signal for for them to be
able to watch
people oh my gosh the calypso
yeah it was beautiful but what was what
was jacques cousteau like
beautiful camera great beautiful man but
his son was amazing too
that's what i know they all were great
yeah
philippe passed but you know it's uh
it's very
difficult you know
now when i remember jacques told did he
used to send philippe on all the [ __ ]
that was too tough for him to do
like felipe is gonna go to the bottom of
the ocean
with no apparatus he's gonna hold his
breath he's gonna go down
and release air all the way up i was
like okay
it's like any father philippe go down
there
right jacques had that had the iron
lungs and
philippe had just a snorkel and he had
to go down there and deal with it yeah
so you know he was a you know
quite an inexperienced uh jacques was an
experienced expert i think that would
have made catherine very
kathleen very happy kathleen very happy
to spend her time
on the diving and and just
um all of the things that he found and
all the things that he was about
right right great
yeah i'm going to do a a film with chris
mcdonald
uh and he's gonna play uh a captain
and i'm gonna be a doc rat i call him
doc rats but i
work on the dots filling up people's
boats kind of thing so
type casting
what brought us all to uh walking with
her
whoo i know i know it's not our faith
it's been very well received by the way
people yes absolutely the the reviews
are
are very good and people are excited
about the film coming out and especially
after this year
you know we could talk about what's
faith-based because i said every movie
would
would be faith-based because it's always
you start someplace and you want to
happen in a better place in the end and
or if you don't it's still a journey and
along that journey
something has to be tested and it's
usually someone's
faith that's tested you know i gotta say
that
you asked the question what got us
involved what got me involved it was
that i got a phone call
from uh um
ross the director producer
and son-in-law of mark manoff the great
uh you know
uh writer and storyteller and
he says mark has written a script for
you
with you for you i took a deep breath
and said whoa that's an extreme
strange call to get i never have had a
call like that in all my years of
doing this work have i ever had anybody
call them and say we wrote this
for you you know well okay
so i think rob listen can i stop i think
ross is like that though
i think if ross went to to mcdonald's
and somebody helped him the manager he'd
say listen
we wrote this script for you he's like i
want magic mcdowell oh my god
i think ron i think that's ross's
you know what i'm gonna i even hate to
say this because it's wrong
but i think that's his move you know all
these dudes have moves man i think but
but i i get i get it but i think you
know ross is
well it's a way of making you feel like
you're the only actor in the world
did you go fishing man you know i got
hooked i got hooked by
by the name mark middoff i got hooked
that's that's
that's true that caught me and i said i
didn't give a [ __ ] what he was saying
how i was saying it
i i love i did uh like i said zootsu and
we did zootsu right at the same time
that they were doing children of a
lesser god
at the mark gaper forum and so i had met
him
and and super intellectual super
energetic
and very very disciplined i mean very
kind of i
never smiled i didn't see him hey how
you doing that was all right really
him and gordon davidson so um
when they told me that he had wanted me
to read his script i said great send it
to me you know i didn't i didn't freak
out and say oh my god
no but i said okay senator i'd like to
read it so i read it
and man it was like uh war and peace
and you know it was like this long
script
with so many words i mean
it was just really written all of it
worked
it all worked but it was just a
man i mean there was a little quiz in
there that would
you know they would rival shakespeare
you know because it was so
intellectually
profound in the way he wrote and so
um anyway i read it and uh i said you
know i told
uh uh mar ross that you know that
the script had to be worked on you know
that it was a brilliant story
but it was just not a movie it was it
was written like a movie
but it wasn't a movie it was almost like
a play true
you know just a long beautiful i mean
you could see the scenes lasting
forever like you're doing a play and but
um so anyway that's what got me started
there it was a story one
written by mark meadow and that was
wrestle's history
we we sat and did the table read and
eddie
says i gotta be on here it's 7 00 p.m
i go it's 1 30 we'll be out here by by
7.
we started at 2 o'clock and by 7 eddie's
like i'm leaving
we weren't done reading the script five
hours later
and then he's like listen i'm sorry man
but i gotta go let's do like 30 pages i
gotta go
uh and then he looks at me before he
goes half of this shit's not going to be
in there
if we do this because there was so much
like there's no way
that could ever that we could ever have
shot all of that
we shot a lot of it we ended up editing
a lot of it you know
i helped edit it and and we added a lot
of our stuff up down you saw it you know
what
we did and what we didn't make it the
screen right
because and i often told them i said you
got to put the camera with them where
the
story is and you got to have the story
moving itself don't
pontificate on on mark's words
you know let let the the story emerge
through the
actors and the silent moments are the
best and that's what made
you know kathleen just like scream
she stole the show i mean we're out here
talking and all this
and she's standing there just looking
wonderful
kathleen goes get out of here you just
get it no it's true
look at them you look at the movie
kathleen and you tell me
the silent moment okay you guys have a
wonderful relationship and then
and then you and kathleen had done
something before
together right a movie that you directed
i think eddie
yeah we did teddy directed the devil has
a name name yeah and i asked kathleen to
come and help me and she did i was very
grateful for that one too
it was really that's a wonderful story
and uh it uh it's good it was a good
time we had a great time and then
when i asked her to come and join us to
do this one
she goes come over to my house sit down
in my
sit down outside i want to read the
script but i don't want to read it
without
you being there i want to read it with
you i go okay we'll read it together
that's great we did yeah well i i know
you had you had
uh you had worked with kathleen before
and you had known george before but you
have never had never worked with him
right before
this so a lot of times like when you
know somebody i'm guessing
when you work with them your
relationship has an opportunity to
change a little bit
did you feel like it did or didn't or
was it just like working with your buddy
on the film this became a love affair on
all levels
everything that i'd ever dreamed about
it was the ultimate
moment i've had in making a film first
of all the story was
a really sweet story i mean people i
guess i don't know what the i i've been
isolated so i don't really know
everything that maybe george knows
but i'm glad that the people are lacking
it you know and uh
as far as it being a faith-based yeah
it's it's got faith in it yes and it's
got
a sense of uh you know second chance
that's really what the movie's about
it's about second chances
and and us being able to have the faith
in ourselves
not in god and somebody yeah it's about
having faith in oneself to get makes you
live
and try to understand yourself to the
fullest so that
theme is magnificent and then working
with kathleen and george
like you know kathleen when when you and
eddie as a
as a as a couple in the movie starts and
you know he
he's not you know you you as a family of
have suffered loss but in
in in a relationship
if one person like this you know you
kept your faith and you you you kept
you the family up but in a relationship
if someone
is can't see for because of the pain
i i think that that might bring both
people down
that the pain is stronger than
somebody's belief in someone else
yeah right and this you didn't give up
on him
and you saw him smile and you saw him
start to rebuild
himself well
i would say that sheila
didn't give up on him because sheila
was a different person than me she has
more faith she's a little purer
she's uh has a little more strength
in that department than i do that's
fun to explore that
and just to backtrack a little
when eddie actually came out
to the house with alex
and he he asked me
if if i would do it after we were kind
of done
playing around with some of the scenes
and i said yes because
it's edward james almost what am i going
to do
say no it was
lucky for me to be able to work with him
and to work with mark medoff i've worked
with mark before
so it just seemed a little too
fortuitous
and i had to i had to take the leap
so and what's there a favorite part when
you're going with a script together
was there a something when you were
reading the script that clicked and and
made you say yeah
i'm in or was it just working with the
people you're working with
yeah there's this really kind of uh
you know could have been this really
cheesy
moment in the script
and i decided to kind of cut against it
and just
talk to him like i would talk to him
and he was a
so yeah you could do that or you could
say that god's saying
this and eddie was
he's an actor who's just right there
like you're not gonna you're not gonna
throw him any sliders that he's not
going to
see you know what i mean so so there's a
safety there and there's a freedom as an
actor
and that doesn't always happen i've
worked with two other
i won't say who leading men where they
say okay
you're up tomorrow and you're supposed
to act like you've been married for 30
years
and uh go i said wait a minute
i don't even know what this guy likes to
eat for dinner
how am i going to act like i've known
him for 30 years
so i would have had to request
just a lunch or just a meeting just as
something
where i can kind of see if i can find a
connection
because i i don't like that
playing the wife thing right there is
something really going on there i'm not
interested
yeah how about you george
i think that's i think that's very true
well
it is the largest bit of
um acting that that i had done
and interestingly enough um
i wasn't afraid of it you know when i
did that movie about the robotics team
and i didn't i wanted to produce it but
i didn't want to be in it
and then they said that they wouldn't do
it unless i was in it and it was a lot
these guys were younger guys and in the
beginning
they were acting like younger guys and
then i had to do something that wasn't
really
you know good for all of us i had to say
listen man
i don't give a [ __ ] what you guys do
when you're away
but singing songs in between takes and
playing trivia in between takes
is is not we can't do that like we have
to take this
this work we have to take serious and
they just they really weren't there
and i did that early enough that it got
them there and because i was like i'm
not gonna
sit here while you guys are playing
frank sinatra trivia
and expect us to our performances to be
to be worth seeing but this one was
different and
i hadn't i rehearsed on some but not the
way eddie
wanted to rehearse this and i and i
wasn't into going every day all day for
a month
just because of my own as a stand-up you
don't have to do that
in tv you don't have to do that but this
was
a this was a real film and
it could not have worked any other way
because whatever
insecurities i had or whatever thinking
that this was a huge part and i had to
play this guy herb that was all of these
different things
being with eddie all those days and then
meeting you
and then us reading it and then us all
getting
along really well um
protected me from
i i would say my instincts were good
protected me from talking myself out of
a good performance
i was prepared where usually i would
have maybe
not have dug as deep but the fact that
you've made me do that i don't think
i'll work any other way
now going forward that that really got
got us together and made a stay together
and i think that's
why the ending is so emotional because
you know meeting him in
1988 and then doing this and then
us all becoming in love with each other
and then he says
is this it uh i think herb knows that
he's
probably going on somewhere else his
mission was accomplished
he finally was able to to pass through
so when he says
is this it and then our moment there
with the tear and then our moment
together
uh was just really almost a graduation
from stand-up to tv guy
to being in a movie with
the writer and the actors all
of academy award nominee and uh uh
caliber so
um and i'm glad it was toward the end
because
i needed to earn all of those all of
those things i remember kathleen coming
and going
hey the police want to talk to you and i
wasn't you know shocked
yeah where are they and she said
i came in and i said what's up and she
hadn't come in my trailer you know the
police
they're on to you and what where are
they
she came in to warn me the police are
here they want to talk to you
[Laughter]
but you really delivered you delivered i
mean that's
that's a pretty ballsy part to take on i
mean
you know i said it in in some of the
interviews that i've done
in national on national stuff that
and i told them i said please don't tell
him but i'm going to tell you right now
you're a great athlete and what i mean
by that
is that you really commit yourself
to when you whatever you're doing in the
form of athletic system
and you shoot you can see that in your
golf your golf game is
really good you're as good as the pros
you could be you could have been a pro
if you wanted to
and you chose to continue to use it but
you know you play it so well
well when you were done with this movie
george
you're a better actor than you are a
golfer
and you're a hell of a golfer george
and i was so happy because it was hard
for me it was hard for me to say okay
george is going to try to do this and i
hope that george doesn't bring george
because if george comes and george is
going to be playing
curb and that is not her
we need her we don't need george we need
herb
and so and he did it i remember
rehearsing and when we started rehearsal
yeah he did
and when we started rehearsals in this
room
you know and and uh my assistant would
be reading all the other parts and we'd
be reading
the the the story and then you know ross
was there and it was just the ross my
assistant and george and myself and
we'd be standing there going through the
the pieces all of a sudden
like about the second or third time we
did
this one scene it locked in in such a
way
that i looked at him and i said you son
of a [ __ ]
you did it man you're remember i
remember telling you that do you
remember when i said that
i said you know this is amazing george i
i
i'm very very excited i can't tell you
man you just went through the roof man
and that's one of the great things
because people
are gonna they're gonna laugh we're fun
we stay fun we're still up and going
around
but the the truth
of the situation was so pure
and so beautiful that's what happened
with kathleen and me we
hid it and boy we went there and we
loved each other
and it was just gorgeous gorgeous
moments of understanding
with um years of being together i mean
you could
feel how long how much we loved each
other and how much we could play with
each other and how much
you know we cared about each other now
and through the look at
the only thing i could ever say to
anybody is listening to this right now
is may you bury your parents
and may your children bury you and may
their children bury them
and may that chain never be broken
because if it's broken you're going to
not live a life that you thought you
were going to live i don't care
how good you are as a person you're
ruined your life is completely
off kilter and that's what the story
starts off with
people don't know what the story is but
i got to tell you it's which starts
i'll give you the beginning and that'll
be the only time we're really going to
make it
uh you know possible for you to
understand something because
basically when we start this movie off
we start off with the burying
of you know sheila kathleen my wife and
myself
and my daughter jessica met often
mark madoff's daughter you know daughter
and then she played audrey on mobliamo
and we're standing
at a funeral where our three-year-old
my granddaughter her daughter and and
i am over
no more i am done i don't want to hear
none of this [ __ ] that they're saying at
the funeral site
i can't take it and i've lost all my
faith and of course
sheila is just holding on man and just
saying come on man
cut it out stop it and my daughter's
saying keep the faith and say have
no faith what are you talking about
faith
you know we're burying my granddaughter
next to her father who was a doctor who
got killed in the war
as a doctor before the baby was born
you know and and no i take that back he
was alive
he did get to see the baby he was alive
we have photographs of him in the baby
and and and he ends up dying
and then we're burying the baby we have
there's a coffin coffin man ah
that's how the movie starts and who what
happens uprides
herb and i don't i don't see him he sees
us but we don't see him
upright herb and herb looks unbelievably
weird
and he's real i'll tell you i will tell
you this
the amount of takes that that pastor
needed to take
and she was reading it out of her book
i thought that was going to be four dead
bodies me you and kathleen
and the little one right there you're
just like is this
and then we went to the church and did
it you're like
are we are we all
she could read it out of the oh
everywhere we're looking at each other
like you know we're standing there you
know very peaceful i'm all in white i'm
looking at you guys you're
like no
bob lambert took care of that yeah
my mom was amazing yeah beautiful job
robert's amazing
great editor great and you know in this
in in these things you know i remember
i've said it on this thing before like
i used to look at my grandmother when i
was a teenager and my grandmother
my grandfather wasn't biological my
grandmother was
and i would look at her and think if
anything happened to this woman
with me still growing up becoming a man
i don't think
that i would have survived losing my
grandmother i know i wouldn't have
and i and and fortunately she didn't
pass when i was a young teenager
but i wasn't surrounded by people that
would have made me feel better
with that loss so thankfully
i never had to experience that even
though she wasn't particularly
kind to me but that was just a result of
her own life
you can't you know teach somebody but
um thankfully that
when people you know suffer loss that we
have to
keep going for the people that are
around us
but i think it's it may be it's the
hardest thing to ever do
when you get older and all your friends
go like brian
this dude is the [ __ ] grim reaper
everybody that guy comes in contact with
passes
oh no sorry sorry guys that's why we did
this
we did this on zoom today for a reason
right right right
a lot of but what do you think that is i
don't know guys i'll live near
del corning or i lost a couple of my my
very good friends
best friends from high school in their
50s and then uh
my wife just i mean it's it's every year
it's been a lot a lot of people so
uh it's it's one of those things where
you appreciate but my question to you
is that it's a faith-based movie
and you're you're professional actress
you've been doing it for many many years
but is there something that
you take from a movie like doing this
for months on end
do you take some of that with you do you
feel a bit a little bit more
faithful when you leave the set off the
last day or or is it just kind of like
you just live your life because i know
you're on your your own
your own person but does some of that
ever sink in because
kathleen your character is very very
faithful in the movie yeah i didn't take
any of that with me i wish i
had i think she's a little bit crazier
i think i think kathleen's weight loss
i think she's a little bit way more than
we thought like i think you know she's
like this
you know oh that was awesome that was
perfect no
but uh but i tell you what i did take
from this film i had
more fun on this film and then probably
any other film
that i've i've done with these guys
i mean you all seem like such a family
forever
you're right i i was lucky enough to
spend a couple days on set and be a
mouse on the corner and you guys got
along like family you just
literally enjoyed each other's company
which is very very cool to see
and it's a big loss when you lose that
kind of
family you have to go through a grief
period you know like i knew
george in terms of you know being a
comedian and everything but i didn't
know
the warmth and the sensitivity and the
caring
and you know he's great fun but
i want to know what what else is going
on there and
and and then really all of those
qualities
really lent to his work so
i'm a little bit dark but you know i i
you know fell in love with you
and i love daddy and like when i see you
right now
you know i love you so from coming from
the movie and doing that
you know i've done a lot of movies but i
don't revere
the people that i did as much as i hold
you in
high regard kathleen i re you're really
just a fantastic person and a wonderful
actress
and i i love you i feel i feel you know
we all were together and i think
listen it's no secret eddie if you were
available you'd be
eddie would be in the santa monica
mountains
but but uh you know it's um
it's wonderful that we were able to put
mark's last words
yeah he had written and make them come
to life and although
he really unfortunately didn't look well
the joy that radiated from this guy's
face and his smile and his body
when his body was was shutting down and
he was starting to
what he had written was coming to
fruition like he
somebody who had suffered loss i think
he ultimately knew that
where he was because some days he'd show
up and some days he wouldn't but when he
was there
to have him look at you with that face
of
his smile and radiating that love that
he
or put his hand on you and you know
watching to the monitor
brilliant that's the best and you know
it's interesting
uh because ross
really made us feel comfortable and free
to sort of do what we wanted to do
and and so you consequently you don't
think about them quite as much because
he did what most directors are supposed
to they're supposed to be kind of
invisible
and he kind of you know you don't think
of him as much of
a presence as all of us but
but he was he was there you know he
helped us
do whatever we wanted to do i think that
style of directing
because you know you you both
you know it's got to be it's got to be
difficult for
you for a director to slide into that
especially with mark out of vision and
but to be in control and yet be
invisible and allow you to make your
your choices acting um
and acting i think is the strength of a
director that
allow you to do those things and boy was
this fun watching youtube golf
i don't know what about that but also
but also i was
i was telling brian that you came
out uh in 30 plus degree weather
when you didn't have dialogue and you
stood there with us
and i'm not sure many actors would do
that
oh i believe in being a good soldier
and i'm irish and that's nothing
you get paid for sit standing there you
know
how tough can it be all those little
kids were freezing
i couldn't stand that part though
yeah well that that that brings me to uh
the athletic part edward
you have your golf swing looks great in
the movie
what and you had said that you were not
an avid golfer so
did it take a little bit of training to
get to that point because your golf
swing looks fantastic
yeah well look it it looks like i
haven't swung
a golf club in 35 years and that's what
it was supposed to be
it was not supposed to look like the guy
had been training
and it was a really good golfer so
what happened which i was lucky they
gave me enough time to
hit balls and when you start to really
understand and i'm baseball player so i
kind of have that eyeball kind of
coordination
but it's a lot different hitting a ball
that is moving is really
really difficult especially when it's
coming at 100 miles an hour and it's
doing all kinds of turns and stuff it's
just like
really ridiculous but you train you get
yourself to the point where you learn
how to
read the ball and boom you can hit it
and you see it happening all the time
but to hit a little ball
that's not moving that's on the ground
and control it oh my god it's it's
probably one of the most beautiful
sports i've ever tried
to be understanding of because i played
the game
you know when throughout the years i've
done a lot of
work with the people that put on golf
tournaments and we do fundraisers and i
go there and i play and everybody
but we always played scramble i never
had played an entire game
18 holes with me hitting the ball and
getting it in there
and going to every hole and doing myself
i never did that
i to this day i've never really done it
um
you know i i played somewhat with uh
with george but i gotta tell you
when i started to hit the ball and i
started to focus and i started to
understand the the beauty of it's like
ballet
it's like it's it's so rhythmic it's so
it's like music it's like dance it's
like
it's beautiful it's like but one with
wow
and you feel it you could feel the the
in the in the
in the the the club you feel the
the presence of of understanding that
just like whoa
man and it's just like oh it's beautiful
so i started doing that i hit thousands
of balls
thousands wow thousands you really did
uh turn into into someone that
if they watch the film you will believe
that this person's a golfer there was a
guy that i played with
at the atnt on a sunday and he was a
roofer
who was a good golfer who went to
qualify in school and qualified and he
had a couple exemptions one of them was
the att
so little did i know that even back in
2004 i was playing with a guy
who was so unbelievably
overtaken by pebble beach as any
as i wouldn't say not a professional
golfer would but by
anyone who was able to play there as a
golfer
much less as a guy who had qualified but
his eyes were wide open
and and were walking on this sunday and
he just can't believe it
and little did i know that in 2004 i was
really kind of playing with the guy that
would have become
you know joe mobliamo later on
and he hit thousands of balls and then
tell everybody eddie when kathleen hit a
golf ball
how well she hit it on once on camera
on camera i got to tell you that was the
beauty of what
you talk about having faith and you had
to talk about having been touched by the
hand of god
um kathleen we had a scene to do
and the scene was that i'd put the ball
down and she would
start off by swinging the club hitting
the ball and watching
go and you know she's athletic very
athletic and
and i don't know if she's swung the golf
club she's been golfing she knew how to
golf
but i don't know how long it had been
how long had it been since you swung a
club
and hit the ball can you probably 10
years old
and the very first shot the very
first take the very first
moment she stands there and we're
laughing and just
it's just beautiful beautiful feeling
between us and i mean
everything just feels so real so honest
so pure
and she just stands up and goes oh boy
whoa straight out man a beautifully
involved
and we looked at each other and started
laughing she ran into my arms and
we hugged each other and it was all
facts man it was
it was that was the one time i really
did pray
please god please god don't let me f up
in front of these guys
i want to hit this ball
it's hard it's hard to do man if you've
never played the game and don't
take it so lightly when you see it being
played and you see these guys doing what
they do with the little ball and how
they control it
it's unbelievably difficult it's one of
the most difficult games in the world
you know i i think i think it's it's
quite
a world man that that brought us all all
together
you know my journey with edward of
um you know seeing him
i saw him in zootsu in high school
and i'd never seen a
first of all never seen a play but then
to see
that play and to see that guy
that pachuco was
just eye-opening man for for a young
chicano
a young chicano kid um
and you know following you kind of seen
you and seen in your films and to
end up all together and to end up like
this you know it's been
a year and a half since we did it and if
you look at us you
it would look like we've been you know
together
since then but you know
walking with her is is a is
i think people will understand that they
don't think there's been a time that we
need a movie like this
uh more than this this past year yeah
um especially with so much division
within
this country that if there's one thing
that
would bond us it would be our faith yeah
yeah you would hope so i hope so i mean
i i i'm not a religious person i don't
i think it's all very interesting all
the stories
and the the fables of the different
religions but i just go
so one person calls it buddhist so one
person calls it yahweh one person calls
whatever
what difference does it make you know
and people are different colors so what
i mean if you believe in god you think
he made a mistake
i mean yeah
well i think he may have made one
mistake by and show that notes again
he overcommitted on this one a little
bit
outside of that world well thank you
guys for spending
uh this time with us right here brian
hey oh my god oh my god
i met you and thanks for hanging
out with us backstage in portland that
was very nice as well and
edward what a pleasure what a pleasure
to have you on thank you guys so much
oh brian please thank you i love you
both you guys
thank you kathleen all right eddie thank
you guys
you